all right we got a Big Show and thank  you I know  thank you I know why you're happy you're  you're not in in line waiting to see a  dead body I I  Jesus  watching the Queen's funeral I don't  tell me how it ends I'm only on season  three  lady buried I mean I've thrown out bread  twice and she died I'm telling you this  has been  but I said this last week the British  people do not [ __ ] with them with the  queen [ __ ] they take it seriously did  you see David Beckham  stood in line for 13 hours  really and they said how did you prepare  to do something so so long and boring he  said I played soccer  but we had a death in this country too  this week Ken Starr died can remember  Ken's  a little different reaction yes Ken  storm every prosecuted Clinton with the  Monica Lewinsky scandal and but the  joke's on him because now that Roe  versus Wade has been overturned blow  jobs are more popular than ever  [Applause]